hey we've got to mention the night
manager Tom Hiddleston I mean what a
huge success that thing was it's on in
America now isn't it yes sir just um
episode three this week yeah and what's
it on over there am CMC AMC I'm
recording it oh I see yes but now you've
already said no more but haven't BBC
said there is war what's the truth tom
well um
goodness okay but the truth is we have
got we've got to the end of the
adaptation of the novel yes
so the night manager the novel by John
Licari has been adapted there's no more
night manager to adapt no more night to
manage that's far why did the influence
of isn't it his son has the production
company that makes it that's right yeah
so there will be more want there
you'll think of something else that
manager do I was the day manager now
very quickly it we must ask you James
Bond Tom Hiddleston's what's the scoop
what's going on this is that listen to
that yeah uh well Graham what can I tell
you I don't know um I don't even talk to
you about no no no one's talking no
one's talked to me you're allowed to
talk about it if they talk to you about
it or is there a non-disclosure even in
the chat I always talk to you about it's
I think it's come as about because in
the night manager I've placed by and we
all know that the you know in the
iconography of British culture there is
a spy that we all know and his name is
James Bond some people have made the
link also I've always wanted to see him
yodel
and you're just watching Sam be sad and
it's really powerful you go hang on a
second what's my line a demonstration of
my hidden talent at polled on all deaths